Did you get x equals 1 or x equals 4? If so, well done. Let's see how we got
these answers. We know when we're solving absolute value equations that we have
to split it into two cases. We have the case when 2x minus 5 is positive, when
it will equal 3. And we also have the case when 2x minus 5 is negative 3. So
we're going to solve each one of these equations independently. When we add 5 to
both sides of the equation here we get 2x equals 8. Which means x equals 4 when
we divide both sides by 2 and when we solve this equation add 5 to both sides I
get 2x equals 2 and when I divide both sides by 2 I get x equals 1. x equals 1
and x equals 4 are the solutions to this first absolute practice problem. let's
try a few more.